Desperate Housewives
star Felicity
Huffman is finally speaking out
about her role
in that college admissions
scandal known as Operation Varsity Blues.
Huffman, as you may recall,
pleaded guilty
to paying $15,000
to falsify her daughter's SAT scores.
It's a crime that sent the Emmy
winning actress to prison.
Stephanie, Steph, CNN,
Stephanie Elam is here with the story.
And Stephanie
Huffman says
she initially thought
her arrest was a joke.
Yeah, she did not think that anything
this serious would happen to her.
And, you know, she was one of 33
wealthy parents
who were using that wealth
and their influence
to work to try
to get their kids to cheat,
to get them into these top
notch colleges.
She says the way it went down
and this is the first time
we're hearing from her,
she really did
not think it was a real deal.
In fact,
take a listen to what she told
our affiliate KABC.
They woke my daughters up at gunpoint.
Again, nothing new
to the black and brown community.
Then they put my hands behind my back
and handcuffed me
and I asked if I could get dressed
and I thought it was a hoax.
She says hindsight being 2020,
that she really felt like
she was going to be a bad mother
if she did not go through with this plan
as it was all coming to her,
as she was hearing about this
and that she wasn't going
be able to get her daughter into school
without doing it.
In fact,
listen to a little bit
more of how she explains her
decision process to arrive where she did.
I had to give my daughter a chance
at a future.
And
so it was sort of like
my daughter's future,
which meant I had to break the law.
I kept thinking, turn around.
Just turn around.
And to my undying shame, I didn't.
Yeah, she talks a lot about her shame.
She also apologized, quote,
to the students and families
that sacrificed
and worked really hard to get to
where they are going legitimately.
In December 2019,
she was sentenced to 14 days in prison.
She also got a year of probation,
250 hours of community service
on top of a fine of $30,000 Jake.
Why are you speaking out now?
That's what everyone wanted to know.
It's like, why now?
Like, why are we talking about this?
Well, it has a lot to do
with that community work
that she started doing.
She started volunteering
at an organization
called A New Way of Life.
It's a nonprofit
that helps previously incarcerated women
get back on their feet
with housing, clothing,
job training, all of that.
And so she started working there.
The founder of the organization said
that she was just going
to put Huffman at a desk,
but instead she said
no, I really do want to work.
So she started
coming up with exercise program.
She started organizing the donations
that were
they were getting,
and it's
now joined the board of directors.
So really putting in the work
and now trying to use her infamy
in this case
to highlight
the good work of this organization
in South L.A..
All right,
Stephanie Elam, thank you so much.